80 auraient d'être avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est une journée qui se veut formatrice
pour vous qui se veut l'occasion de
couvrir toutes sortes de sujets qui vont
vous annulez de toutes sortes de
manières moi le sujet dont je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui c'est l'art de la
question qui ici est appelée à vendre
ses dossiers dans une entreprise par
exemple ou auprès de ses collègues dans
un cours avec lequel vous fait lever la
main d'accord qui ici hausse à faire
face à de la résistance dans certains
cas qui est appelé à prendre le pouls
des fois on se trouve qu'ils se pensent
loti justement tout à l'heure la
conférencière faisaient des faces et
tout le long du doubs et qui ont à
prendre le pouls savoir comment ça va
l'art la question c'est un outil qui est
avoir porté pour installer le dialogue
quand vous êtes en train par exemple
d'interagir avec des gens souvent quand
on présente un dossier quand on a à
faire une présentation pour aller
chercher du budget pour aller vendre une
idée par exemple évidemment on se
prépare on a une idée claire si on est
bien préparé un argumentaire et tout a
conseillé le sens qu'on veut donner à
notre notre affaire mais le but souvent
quand on veut faire passer une idée
c'est d'interagir avec la personne c'est
d'amener la personne avec soi-même qui
ici est un patron et a influencé des
employés à m'élever d'accord peut-être
que vous êtes président peut-être que
vous êtes prêt destiné à ce métier là et
que vous ne savez pas encore moi ce que
je peux vous dire c'est quand j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à l'heure de la
question j'ai évidemment fait de la
recherche j'ai interviewé différentes
personnes
je collabore moins fréquemment avec
l'école des cadets dirigeants ici que
j'interviens aussi ou exécutive un
billet maggie lâcher c'est justement sur
le thème de l'art de la question puis je
parle à mes collègues
professeur aussi qui s'appelle alain
gosling vous connaissez peut-être alain
enseignes pour voyons les ressources
humaines allez une petite heure
marouette isabelle sa tombe tellement
bien que tu t'intéresses à cette chose
là il on vient de faire une étude auprès
des chefs d'entreprise du québec qui
venait de conduire une recherche auprès
de soixante dix huit chefs d'entreprise
du québec sur comment est-ce qu'ils
exercent leur leadership aujourd'hui
comment est-ce que les choses changent
et ça le donné lieu à un livre qui
s'appelle parole de p dg qui est très
intéressant vous avez peut-être vu le
sur les tablettes
savez vous ce qui ressort de sa les
grands patrons une des choses qui est
leur outil de travail principal c'est
leur habilité à poser les bonnes
questions
alors ce qu'on peut voir aujourd'hui on
va d'abord s'attarder aso lors la
question à quoi ça sert
premièrement deuxièmement s'il vous dit
why ci dessus c'est intéressant cette
chose là je vais couvrir avec vous c'est
quoi les 5 clés à maîtriser pour passé
maître dans l'art de la question parce
qu'on impose tout des questions je
convaincu que dans votre dans votre
emploi dans votre dans vos équipes de
travail vous en poser des questions mais
est-ce que vous atteignez les résultats
que vous voulez ça c'est une autre
histoire
d'accord donc on va s'attarder à sa lors
la question les cinq catégories où les 5
clés pour maîtriser l'art de la question
puis ensuite je vais vous donner des
trucs pour justement exercer votre
influence dans les situations dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
alors est-ce que ça va bouger cette
chose là j'ai besoin vous dit rien merci
peut-être que ça comme montrer que ça
veut pas bouger
je sais pas la personne derrière alors
ben écoutez je vais avancer si
éventuellement sa clique l'attendait
minutes je vais je vais attendre encore
un petit moment parce que je suis pauvre
moi je suis visuel vrai j'ai quand même
besoin d'avoir quelques mots lot
d'équipements de toute manière en
attendant d'avoir
ah ok la question c'est quoi au juste
quand on réfère à la notion de l'art de
la question moi je la définition que je
vais vous faire un saut simple il ya
trois aspects à maîtriser si on veut
être considéré comme un maître dans
l'art de la question en passant c'est
vrai quand on m'a présenté tout à
l'heure on a dit que j'étais une coach
professionnel moi j'ai appris le métier
de coach alors rejeté gestionnaire en
entreprise j'ai travaillé en entreprise
j'ai été gestionnaire pendant une
vingtaine d'années et j'ai appris le
métier de coach alors que j'étais encore
gestionnaire je vais vous dire une chose
ça a pas mal changé ma vie ma façon
d'aborder les choses et puis évidemment
toute la notion de la question est très
près centrale là dedans
en clair la question qu'est ce que c'est
la première chose il ya trois aspects ok
qu'on doit avoir on qu'on doit maîtriser
si on veut être considéré maître dans
l'art de la question la première chose
c'est de maîtriser la forme de la
question la forme de la question je vais
y revenir tout à l'heure là il faut
tendre vers ce qu'on appelle des
questions ouvertes
bien sûr dans certains cas la question
fermée nécessaire ok quand tu veux close
un dossier quand tu veux préciser des
choses il faut être capable évidemment
de maîtriser cette chose là mais être
conscient qu'une forme ouverte de
question vaut créer l'interaction
première chose
deuxième élément est celui là est bien
important c'est l'attitude de
questionnements de quoi vous avez là
qu'on se poser vos questions
moi je travaille beaucoup avec les
dirigeants d'entreprise je les vois dans
les comités de direction je voit les
gens sortir des salles de comité de
direction un peu apeurée pourquoi parce
qu'on leur posait des questions qui
étaient peut-être douane mais l'attitude
était un peu méprisante ou la latitude
était peut-être impulsive où un patient
puis il faut savoir que l'acte de
questionnement est important donc il
faut vouloir rentrer en relation avec
les gens à qui on parle quand on réfère
à la notion de l'attitude donc une
certaine ouverture une certaine patience
aussi et puis donc ceci est un des
aspects et puis l'autre aspect
quilles et puis à mon avis c'est pour ça
que les patrons s'intéresse autant à la
notion de l'art de la question c'est que
quand on pose des questions il faut
avoir une intention stratégique qu'est
ce que vous voulez accomplir quand vous
avez en réserve des questions à poser
par exemple quand vous voulez vendre un
dossier dans un cas comme celui-là
faudrait que votre intention stratégie
que ce soit d'obtenir le mandat par
exemple si vous avez en face de vous des
gens justement qui résistent mais vous
l'avez anticipées vous savez qui
pourrait vous poser si vous déstabiliser
en vous posant telle ou telle question
l'idée c'est d'avoir en réserve dans
votre poche derrière en sachant que
c'est un outil qui vous aide à entrer en
relation donc de savoir que si vous
poser quelques questions ça va vous
permettre de désamorcer la résistance on
va en voir tout à l'heure quelques
exemples pour te donner du sens à cette
chose là donc on ne peut pas être un
maître dans l'art de la question si on
n'a pas une pleine conscience de ces
trois dimensions là maintenant si on
s'attarde aux clés à maîtriser pour
passé maître dans l'art de la question
la toute première est gelée indiqué tout
à l'heure c'est la notion de maîtriser
la question ouverte
je vais vous donner un exemple les deux
questions qu'on voit ici la belgique et
vous dans votre milieu de travail mais
je n'ai vous en train dé car agir avec
avec vos collègues et tout est ce que tu
crois qu'on va y arriver
un au tulle quand je pense à ma
suggestion je trouve que des belles
question maintenant c'est beau c'est
comme enthousiaste et tout mais ce sont
des questions fermées dans les deux cas
c'est possible de dire oui c'est
possible de dire non donc quelqu'un peut
très bien se sortir de cette
conversation l'eau la plus belle que
j'ai vu parce que comme je vous ai dit
jma
mon entreprise je forme les
gestionnaires je les forme être des
leaders inspirants qu'on pratique l'art
la question combien de fois je vous
dirais peut-on la moyenne au bâton quand
on fait les exercices là dessus là où je
dis aux gens qui est préparé des
questions et tout mon dieu cette fois
sur dix les questions sont fermées la
plus drôle que j'ai entendu c'était dans
une formation je donne en anglais
c'était ayew open to know i deals sécu
ou pareil s'il y avait le mot open
dedans c'était quand même je mangerai de
limbé plus un mais mon point c'est qu'on
s'en rend pas compte
donc on sera en pot qu'on va poser des
questions fermées donc faut être
vigilant par rapport à ça c'est possible
que vous ayez pensé par de ce sommet
vous soyez capable plutôt d'avoir des
questions de formuler des questions
qu'on appelle diriger c'est à dire que
vous soufflez la réponse à l'intérieur
de la question moi je dit quentin
affirmation affaire souffel affirmation
si tu as une recommandation à faire
c'est quelque chose de différent
un exemple de ce qu'est ce que vous
pensez le reporter sept tableaux dans un
mois mais dans un cas comme celui-là je
dirais qu'il faut plutôt dire mes
recommandations et qu'on reporte le
projet d'un mois pour telle ou telle
raison
comment est-ce que vous réagissez face à
cette chose-là voyez-vous puis l'autre
défi qu'on a c'est quand on se dit ah en
week en passant ça se pratique quand on
veut voir ça le tout un tout à l'heure
l'autre défi c'est que souvent on se
dirige en pratique son malheur la
question j'aime ça et l'on va poser une
première question il n'y a pas de
réponse clan où on enchaîne avec une
deuxième question une troisième et où il
a tout à coup nos interlocuteurs sont un
peu bousculé et leur à travers ces
belles questions là qu'on va formuler va
peut-être avoir une de fermer qui permet
à nos interlocuteurs de sortir de la
conversation c'est parce qu'on veut
évidemment on veut créer l'interaction
rappelez vous ça nous prend une
intention stratégique
alors voyez vous ici je vais vous
montrer deux exemples de questions
ouvertes
la première qu'est ce que tu penses de
cette orientation vous êtes en train de
faire un dossier
vous avez mis quelques hypothèses sur la
terre sans ne tourne pas mal comment
vois-tu qu'on va y arriver
voyez-vous c'en est une autre exemple de
questions ouvertes
le défaut qu'elles ont mais là ça nous
amène à la deuxième caractéristique ces
deux questions là sont bien sont ouverts
mais ils sont tellement large que on
peut passer une demi-heure à échanger là
dessus quand je vais travailler avec mes
exécutive mbiye l'homme et 40 dirigeants
il pense une journée jeux les drills
pendant une journée sur l'art de la
question je vais vous dire si j'en la
difficulté parce qu'ils sont habitués
dire quoi faire ils savent comment faire
qu'ils sont pas capables de détecter
dans quels cas ils doivent donner la
direction puis dentelle quoi il faut
dans quel faux il faut créer
l'interaction donc moi je leur donnais
comme truc 1,7 travailler pour que tes
questions ouvertes fois plus resserrée
qui soit plus juste
voyez-vous fait que donc la deuxième clé
c'est que nos questions soient formulés
avec plus de justesse
c'est à dire que quand tu répond à une
question est ce que je vais vous en
donne un exemple garder pour regardons
celui l'eau mettons vous présentez votre
e et tout pas la fin vous disent que
vous en pensez ben là c'est ce qu'on
peut partir très largement mme admettons
que vous êtes en train de présenter un
dossier à des hadiths collègues et là
vous voulez que votre projet passe pour
souvent de longs rappelez vous on est en
situation d' influence ici on n'est pas
en situation d'autorité voulant faut
vous amener les gens avec vous pour les
amener à réfléchir puis à adhérer à
votre suggestion donc comment est ce que
tu vois qu'on va pouvoir déployer ça
dans ton unité
voyez vous c'est pas du tout la même
question donc en est un qui est plus
juste une troisième clé est ici je vous
dirais que c'est probablement le plus
grand piège quand on veut
maîtriser l'art de la question on a en a
eu sur les silences
on a eu le vide alors quand les gens
d'une chose puis en passant quand
quelqu'un vous pose une question qu'elle
est juste qu'elle est ouverte qu'elle a
une bonne intention stratégique qui voit
une affaire la personne là c'est à
répondre tout de suite là c'est parce
qu'elle est en train de réfléchir est en
train de forger son opinion par rapport
à ça donc vous êtes à la bonne place
c'est quand il ya un silence en face de
vous des fois les patrons vont me dire
oui mais là je pose la question qui
vraiment ne se passe rien alors dans un
coup comme celui là il faut reformuler
cette même question là donc apprivoiser
vraiment les silences
c'est un peu ce que je viens de vous
dire est la 5ème clé et vous êtes
probablement en début de carrière
si vous avez eu la chance de faire des
critiques toutes sortes de tests de
personnalité pour connaître votre style
de gestion votre style d'intervention et
tout il ya des natures qui sont plus
prédisposés avec l'art de la question
donc des profils qui sont plus
conciliateur
les profils sont plus analytique aussi
parce que vous avez une mentalité
d'investigateurs si vous êtes plus
directif c'est peut-être moins naturel
mais sachez que si vous êtes directif
vous avez la possibilité de développer
cette chose-là donc connaître la qualité
de l'écouté et trois mots clés il faut
être patient dans l' écoute donc il faut
être attentif non verbale et tout est
ici aussi
donc ce sont les deux choses là qui sont
les principales y en a une troisième qui
est l'objectivité
souvent quand on porte un dossier on a
travaillé fort sur ce dossier là on
pense qu'on a raison on a raison bien
sûr ceci vous proposer telle et telle
chose me dit vous une chance si vous
présentez si vous écoutez avec une
certaine objectivité et fait des choses
que vous allez entendre que vous n'aviez
pas du tout du tout anticipé
donc ça c'est la 5ème clé quand est-ce
que c'est utile et là vous allez voir il
ya beaucoup de mots tableau mais je veux
je veux quand même
je suis en train de préparer mon
prochain livre qui va porter là dessus
que je me suis dit comment donc les
intentions stratégiques ou est-ce qu'on
peut appliquer lors de la question il y
en a une multitude jusqu'à maintenant là
j'en ai identifié une dizaine
je ne peux pas passer trop de temps
là-dessus je vais plutôt vous montrer
des exemples de questions qui ont une
intention stratégique précise qu'ils ont
la bonne forme et qui peuvent vous
permettre de faire du mélange alors deux
exemples de ça commence que vous pouvez
susciter l'engagement
admettons je sais pas il y avait peu une
main levée pour par exemple parce que
vous êtes des patrons et médian mais
dans vos dossiers là moi je suspecte que
vous avez des gens influents ctd fois la
torre réaliser quelque chose s'était
entendu sur une façon de faire pas
besoin que ce collègue la endosse la
recommandation tôt fait alors une
variante de celle ci dans quelle mesure
je peux compter sur toi
évidemment les mots comptent et puis
c'est à vous de voir leurs commandes
quel choix de vocabulaire vous pouvez
utiliser mais l'esprit ici c'est
d'amener la personne à dire d'un coup tu
moi je voyais je m'engage à ce qu'on
fasse les choses de cette manière là
pour telle ou telle raison
prendre le pouls hockey parce qu'on doit
s'attendre comme réaction de la part des
gens question y part payante hyper hyper
payante
moi j'ai je crois beaucoup dans ce genre
de questions long comment vous validez
la compréhension je pense ouvre la
bouche l'appui on a une idée à faire
passer qu'on veut s'assurer que les gens
sont quand même place que nous
appliquions bien compris qui sont à la
même place donc une formulation et le ya
beaucoup de mots mais danser dans ce koh
seah particulier à ce que j'appelle une
précaution oratoire et c'est le je veux
m'assurer que j'ai été clair parce que
c'est important pour moi ce point là
comment tu retiens qu'est-ce que tu
retiens notre entretien
qu'est-ce que tu retiens notre réunion
voyez vous on a une démonstration
combien fois en nuage à faire changer
nos collègues des souvent on voudrait
pouvoir dire autre chose je garde ce
faux bond cette affaire l'eau
l'hôte il faut qu'on leur fasse un
exemple c'est quoi les solutions qu'on a
de rechange compte que vous envisagez ou
qu'on pourrait envisager que celles qui
sont sur la table
super belle question pour stimuler la
réflexion puis pour corriger le tir et
une que tout à l'heure il y avait
beaucoup de mains qui sont lucas s'est
rapidement d'ailleurs sur comment ce qu
on désamorce la résistance et celle ci
c'est ma préférée de tout cela
s'applique dans tous qui a pu
s'appliquer dans une réunion avec un
équipe
moi j'utilise une variante de sûr je
suis entrepreneur dont je rencontre
beaucoup de gens je vends mes services
et tout donc une variante de ça qu'est
ce qui manque à ce stade-ci pour qu'on
puisse faire ce projet l'eau ou qu'est
ce qui manque à ce moment aussi pour que
vous en duo si la recommandation qu'on
fait dans un comité de direction l'
hyper puissant selon vous la noter que
vous l'utilisez avis ako lieu quand vous
terminez vos présentations au lieu
d'arriver à la fin puis de ramasser vos
papiers à toute vitesse puis d'avoir
votre plus beau sourire puis dire
avez vous des questions vous allez dire
avec beaucoup d'aplomb à ce moment ci
qu'est ce qui manque pour qu'on fasse
dossier là avec vous à niveau passé
maître dans l'art de la question
j'espère vous avoir sensibilisé au
potentiel de l'or de la question pour
exercer votre influence
j'espère vous avoir présenté rapidement
les ingrédients ou les clés qu'on doit
maîtriser pour passé maître dans la
question si j'ai une suggestion vous
faire moi je dis on commence on pratique
et on voit l'incidence que ça alors je
vous remercie et je vous pensez un
excellent joue pas je vous souhaite une
excellente journée